There’s a sort of a funny saying, which
is that whenever people are free to choose
anything they want, they usually choose what
their friends have chosen.
This mimicry that we humans evince is extremely
fundamental.
Therefore, networks provide us a kind of mathematical,
social and biological tool to understand the
kind of fundamental basis for this mimicry
because you copy the people to whom you are
connected primarily and you come to copy them
along a whole variety of traits.
In the workplace these traits might include
things like how energized you are at work
or how innovative you are at work or how cooperative
you are at work or whether you smoke or not
or other health traits.
All these desirable properties -- your productivity,
your innovativeness, your cooperativeness,
your health -- come to depend upon the like
attributes in individuals to whom you're connected.
Our group and other groups have mapped networks
in the workplace, have come to understand
how people are connected to each other and
have used that understanding as a kind of
mechanism or tool, an opportunity for intervention,
in order to call forth from people better
behavior, if you will, more cooperativeness,
more innovativeness, more collaborative-ness
and better health behaviors.
The usual way of understanding workplace organization
is the classic org chart where you have boxes
and names and it's like a tree, but actually
the real work or the real organization of
a workplace looks nothing like that.
It's the way people interact with each other.
It's a more jumble of ties.
It looks more like a jumble of Christmas tree
lights.
So if you can think of a network as every
node, every person is a little light and the
wires connecting them are the ties between
them, and when you take out a jumble of Christmas
tree lights and you put it on the floor and
look at it, actually that's what workplace
networks really look like.
Once you understand those patterns of interactions
you can begin to understand how people influence
each other with respect to health and health
behaviors in the workplace, and once you understand
that pattern of interactions and that pattern
of influence you can begin to think about
ways of intervening in it.
For example, you can identify influential
individuals within the network and target
them with health interventions or you can
identify ways to get groups of people to sign
up for interventions.
And we know that when groups of people, particularly
people who know each other and are interconnected
collaboratively, engage in something such
as a health improvement behavior that they're
more likely to sustain it and more likely
to respond positively.
So once you understand the structure of human
interactions it opens up all kinds of new
vistas, new ways that you can intervene.
In fact, it's not just relevant when it comes
to health—in fact, it's not just relevant
when it comes to health to understand the
network of interactions of, let's say, lay
people or workers or regular old people.
It's also important to understand the pattern
of interactions among healthcare providers.